now Ron I'm told you're working on a  cartoon can you tell me about it  oh I'd love to tell you guys about it  because then it might force them to make  it so this is not in production yet your  negation yeah if you want to see a  cartoon of mine please tweet politely at  sea so tell them that you want to see it  I'm making a cartoon basically a little  world we're wrestling is real and it  controls our entire political landscape  the best the president is also the best  professional wrestler so I'm really just  kind of taking this election to its  logical conclusion this part is called  squashed which is a fun wrestling term  if you know about wrestling if you don't  you probably like that's just a little  funny title in yeah yeah I hope this  gets made me too again tweet at these  you